PETE FRISELLA: Hi, everybody.
My name's Pete Frisella.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Analytics team.
Today I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about Content
Experiments and more so advanced
implementations and
some high level information
for you so that you can
implement Content Experiments
and really take advantage of
the platform and the flexibility
it offers.
So to get started, I'm just
going to go just quickly
around what are experiments,
why are they important.
We'll look at some basics of
implementations, and then
we'll go into some details of
examples and apprise you a
little bit of tips at the end.
So let's start with
experiments.
What is an experiment?
So when you think about Google
Analytics and the kind of user
action model, typically you have
users that are arriving
on a property or a site.
You want them to do something,
and then ultimately, you want
them to reach some
kind of goal.
So if that's the objective,
experiments are a really great
way to test changes to make sure
that those changes are
actually providing better
performance for your site.
So for example, increasing
revenue or maybe time on site,
these might be some objectives
you have for
your website or property.
And Content Experiments allows
you to test any changes you're
making to make sure you're
really making the right choice
and implementing the
right variation.
So why Google Analytics for
Content Experiments?
There's a couple reasons why.
I think the greatest benefit
right off the bat is that you
have all this user interaction
data already, and you can add
experiments now.
So you have it all
in one place.
You get a great set of reports,
and you can segment
based on experiment visits
and things like that.
So it's just really having it
all in one spot and having one
kind of platform to
do everything.
The other thing is we've
introduced this multi-armed
bandit experiments.
There's a lot of resource
information on exactly what
this means, but just from a high
level why this might be
of interest to you, why you'd
want to use this, typically
it's a little bit more efficient
than A-B testing,
but at the same time, it's just
as statistically valid.
And then in many circumstances,
the answer will
come to you a little
bit quicker.
So the whole point here is that
you're reducing the time
for the experiment to run, but
to come out with an objective
that's actually performing
better.
So you're reducing the cost
to run experiment.
Or you can imagine, if you have
a variation, you might
implement one or two different
variations, and you actually
might have one that doesn't
perform that well.
You really want to minimize
that particular variation.
You don't want to be sending
visitors to a variation that's
not doing well.
You want to reduce that cost,
and multi-armed bandit is
really great for that.
And then finally, our platform
is very flexible
because we have APIs.
It allows you to implement
it many different ways.
So you can do things like
server-side experiments.
You can also do experiments
in non-web environments.
So this is pretty unique, and
it's really powerful and gives
you the flexibility to match
up what your business
requirements are with what
your objectives are.
So to get started with
Experiments, there are a few
things that you need
to have in place.
The first thing is you really
need to have, obviously,
Google Analytics implemented
onto your property.
Once you have that up running,
that's kind of
the first basic step.
But you need to make sure you
have some kind of goal or
objective for your property.
That could be a user-defined
goal.
So you might set something up
yourself using the admin or
management configuration.
You can also use pre-defined
goals that we have set up for
Experiments.
So for example, we have things
like you can optimize for
minimizing bounce rates or
increasing page views or time
on site, things like this
that are already
predefined for you.
And then actually you want to
know what the variations are,
what the changes you're going to
make that you want to test.
So this is pretty fundamental
to the whole Experiments
processes that you need to
know-- we're going to increase
this font size or change this
button color or maybe
introduce a new algorithm.
So it's all different variations
of things that you
might want to test.
So let's get a little bit more
into the implementation
basics, and this will kind of
set it up for the examples
that we have later on.
When you look at how to run an
experiment, there's typically
five steps you're going to go
through, regardless of the
platform or regardless of what
the actual objective might be.
The first thing, as I mentioned
earlier, is that you
have to define those
variations.
So what are you going to test?
It could be a whole bunch
of different things.
It depends on your environment,
what's important
to you, and what your
objectives are.
Once you've defined those
variations and you've decided,
OK, we're going to change this
landing page to look like
this, and we're doing to have
four different variations,
then you want to go into Google
Analytics and configure
the Experiment.
So where step one is kind of
outside of Google Analytics,
something that you have to do
on your own using whatever
system that you have, whether
it's a content management
system or maybe you're just
coding it yourself, number two
is where you actually go
to Google Analytics
and configure it.
And that means setting up the
URLs or variation names that
you're going to use,
the kind of traffic
coverage, things like this.
This is all configured within
Google Analytics.
And then once that's set up,
you actually run the
experiment.
The next thing that happens is
when a user comes to the
property and is exposed to the
experiment, then you need to
choose the variation.
So for this particular user, if
we're going to include them
in the experiment, what
variation should we show them?
And there's a couple ways
to handle this.
Google Analytics, the standard
implementation, takes care of
this for you.
And then for more advanced
implementations, it's up to
you to make these decisions.
But we provide the APIs
and the tools to
really help this step.
And then of course, it's
important, are these new or
returning visitors?
And that's going to affect
your variation choice.
Once you've decided which
variation to show them, and
you've actually showed them the
variation, then you need
to send data back to Google
Analytics to indicate this.
So what experiment are we
talking about, and what
variation did you
show that user?
And this gets sent back and is
actually part of the pipeline
for processing and will end
up affecting your reports.
And we'll get a little bit
into that later on.
And then finally, the fifth step
to kind of any experiment
is the outcomes and the reports
that you actually can
view to see how it's performing
while it's running,
and then ultimately what the
outcome of this experiment
was, which variation won, was
there a winning variation, and
how did the other
runs perform.
So this is really obviously
the kind of objective or
outcome you're trying
to get here.
And then from there,
you actually do the
implementation.
If there is a variation that's
won and is better than the
other ones, then you
can implement
that one at this point.
I thought it would be good just
to go over the platform
today and then see how Content
Experiments fits into the
current platform that most
people maybe have seen or are
familiar with.
So when you look at Google
Analytics, the way it works,
the way the platform is
organized, we kind of have
these big areas.
We have Collection, so that's
kind of the measurement of
user actions.
That gets logged, and then
we do some processing.
And the processing is affected
by the configuration that you
have set up.
So if you have goals or filters,
that's done in
configuration and will
ultimately affect what your
reports look like.
So you have this
nice pipeline.
And let's see, where
does Content
Experiments fit in this.
So it's somewhere around here.
It's kind of its own statistical
engine that sits
but interacts with all these
different components.
So when you think about the
steps that we talked about
earlier, the first step, where
you define your variations, is
outside of GA.
But the second step, where you
configure your experiments, is
now interacting with
this platform.
So there's really two main ways
to configure the Content
Experiments.
One is through the web
interface, and the other one
is through the management API.
The third thing is we want
to choose the variation.
So this particular
step involves--
and depending on what
environment you're working in,
if you're doing web, we
provided a library.
It's called the Content
Experiments JavaScript API.
And this library interacts
directly with the Content
Experiments interface and allows
you to use all these
tools through JavaScript.
And it makes it really easy to
interact with the service.
If you're doing non-web
environments, you can still
choose the variation, but it
requires you to go through the
management API.
And the management API allows
you access to all the
different experiments that
you're currently running, and
it provides you the information
you need to make
this decision.
So for example, what variations
do I have for an
experiment?
Which ones are active?
And what are the weights for
those particular variations?
All that information can
be obtained through the
management API.
And that's the information
you need to make
this variation choice.
Whereas on the web, with the
library, you basically just
say, using the JavaScript
library, what's the current
variation that I should use
for this particular user.
So it's a little bit more simple
on the JavaScript side.
But equally, you can do the same
thing from the non-web or
server side through the
management API.
The fourth step was that we
wanted to send experiment data
to Google Analytics.
So once you've chosen a
variation and you've shown the
variation, we need to make sure
that that data gets sent
back to Google Analytics.
If you're doing web-based
experiments through the
browser and you're using
JavaScript, you can use the--
currently, we have analytics.js
and ga.js, the
two libraries for tracking
or measurement.
And you can send data through
those interfaces.
And the way it works is you've
set the variation that you've
chosen, or you're using a
JavaScript library, which will
take care of this for you.
And then that data gets sent
along with hits that you're
sending through ga.js
or analytics.js.
So they're kind of attached
to those particular hits.
If you're doing non-web or
server side, then you want to
use the measurement protocol.
And this allows you to interact
directly with the
Google Analytics service
through HTTP requests.
And that allows you
to send hits
from pretty much anywhere.
And then finally, we have the
outcomes or reporting.
So when you look at the platform
in this model, that
fits in on the reporting end.
And again, you can pull out
data through the Core
Reporting API.
We have some dimensions and
metrics exposed through the
Core Reporting API.
And then also, you could
obviously use the web
interface to look at reports.
And then from an outcome
perspective, if you want to
know which variations have
won and the status of an
experiment, that's also
available through obviously
the web interface, but you can
also create that stuff through
the Management API.
And this allows you, when you
look at the Management API and
what it enables, you can bring
all of the functionality of
experiments to different
environments.
And that means creating them,
monitoring them to see where
they're at, and all these
different steps.
And even your reporting can be
all basically done outside of
the interface, if that's what
you're trying to do.
OK, so we have an idea of how
it all fits together.
Some of the important things
you want to consider when
you're running an experiment,
there's different attributes
that are going to affect what
libraries you should use,
whether you should use
API, Management API.
So the first thing I typically
look at is, OK, if you're
going to run an experiment, are
you going to be doing this
in the web, on the web, like in
a browser, or is this going
to be a non-web environment?
If you're doing web, then
again, use the Content
Experiments JavaScript API, the
library that we provide.
It really simplifies
things for you.
If you're doing non-web
environment, then definitely
use the Management API.
It gives you access to all the
information you need to make
these decisions and
run an experiment.
The second thing is storage.
So when you think about how an
experiment works, when the
user is exposed to an
experiment, at that time, we
need to determine, OK, have
they already seen this
experiment?
If they have, then let's just
show them the variation that
we previously showed them.
And to do that, that means you
have to store some kind of
state somewhere in terms of this
particular user looked at
this variation.
On the browser side, it's
fairly straightforward.
We provide the library, and it
takes care of all that for
you, and it uses--
so for Google ga.js, it uses
cookies to do this.
If you're doing a server-side
implementation, then you may
be able to store stuff on the
server for every particular
user, or you can also use
cookies yourself if you're
doing a web to server, client
server type integration.
But it's something to think
about, like will you be able
to store this information on
the client side, or will I
have to manage this all
on the server side.
And obviously, the server side
one's a little bit more
complex because then you need
to maintain for every user
which variation they've been
shown for an experiment.
And then you also need to store
the details about the
experiment on the server side.
So we'll get a little bit
into that later on.
The other thing is
configuration.
So are you going to use the
web interface, which is a
little bit easier to set up
because it's visual and you
can go through the flow?
But we also have the API,
so if you want to do an
integration where the experiment
is created outside
of GA, then you would
want to use the API.
If you're going to use your own
statistical engine, then
you would actually need to
use the API to create the
experiment.
So these are decisions that the
choice you make is going
to depend on what you're
trying to do.
So if you are using your own
statistical engine, then
definitely API.
Otherwise, you can use
the web or the API.
It's up to you.
And then yeah, optimization
engine.
You can choose your own, if
you want to do your own
optimization, flip a coin,
whatever it is.
You actually have the ability to
do that with this platform.
Otherwise, you can use and take
advantage of the Google
Analytics multi-armed bandit,
that approach.
And you can definitely try both,
and whatever you prefer
to do, we provide the APIs and
the information to do that.
And then lastly is
the variation
choice that you're making.
If you're doing client-side,
definitely I would recommend,
again, for browser, use the
JavaScript library.
Otherwise, you're going to be
making choices on the server
side, then you need to use the
Management API to get all the
experiment data.
And at that point, you need to
do things like determine
whether the user should be
included in the experiment,
also determine what the current
active experiments are.
So this is all done on
the server side.
And we have detailed guides
on how to do this on the
developer site.
So I'll get into that
a little bit later.
So let's look at some high level
implementation examples.
And the whole point of this
session here is really to talk
more about high level steps that
you need to consider when
you're implementing some
of these more advanced
implementations for
experiments.
We do have two solution guides
that were published recently.
One is on Content Experiments
without redirects, and the
other one is running a
server-side experiment.
So this video really complements
these two
documents, so I recommend
that you read--
check out these two
solution guides.
They really go into the details
on how to do this
stuff, and they provide
some code snippets.
And they really explain all the
steps that need to happen
to do most of the experiments.
There's just a few things from
an implementation perspective
that I'm going to talk about
now that really doesn't go
into details, but if you read
these docs combined with what
I'm talking about today, you
should be able to basically
implement pretty much anything
that you'd like to do
regarding Content Experiments.
So definitely check these
two documents out.
We'll provide links
later on for you.
So there is three
implementations that people
have asked me about that aren't
necessarily covered in
specific details in
the documentation.
There's a few little things that
you need to do to make
all these work.
So let's go through them.
One of them is CMS
integration.
So if you have a Content
Management System, it'd be
great to actually integrate
those experiments right into
that system.
So how would you automate
this process, right?
If you think about Content
Management Systems today,
typically someone's sitting
there, writing some new
content or making a
change to a page.
Now, when you make a change to
the page, if you have Google
Analytics set up and you have
objectives, it would be great
at that point to then offer that
person the option at that
point to test this
change before it
actually gets published.
So it doesn't work for every
change that you're doing, but
certain things that are
significant that you're making
significant alterations to your
site, and you really want
to see is this good change, or
is this going to be effective
in terms of improving
our goals.
So it would be great to have
this kind of flow where the
user edits the page, CMS offers
the option to test the
change, and then the
experiment runs.
And then you actually don't
publish anything until you've
concluded the experiment.
And if there's a
clear winner--
and you can test multiple
variations of this change--
then you can actually publish
and finalize that change after
you've already determined that
it's going to improve the
objective or maximize or
minimize what you're trying to
accomplish on your site.
So this would be a great flow
for any CMS vendor, or if you
have an in-house one that
you want to provide this
functionality to your users with
in-house, definitely this
can be done.
And I'll go through now what the
steps would be to get this
accomplished.
So if we think about those five
steps that we have to go
through for kind of an
experiment, the first one is
defining the variations.
So this is--
I mean for CMS, this is great.
CMS is really good at
defining variations.
You can just add new pages
and new content.
And that's pretty much taken
care of through this interface
of the CMS system.
And then you need to configure
the experiment.
So this can be all done
through the API.
So you can imagine, you would
create the variations in the
interface of the Content
Management System.
At that time, it would ask
you if you want to run an
experiment.
And then you would use the
Management API to create that
experiment in Google
Analytics.
There's a few things that you
want to do here, and this is
what people don't always--
or usually ask me, what I let
them know is that when you
create the experiment using the
Management API, there's a
property, an argument
they can set that's
called editable in GAUI.
And if you set this to false, it
will prevent the user from
going into GA and changing that
configuration for that
experiment.
And you might want this because
you're going to manage
it all through the CMS system.
And you want to disable that
specific functionality so that
they don't go in and stop the
experiment early or make
changes because you've set
this up through the API.
And that prevents any changes
in the UI from happening.
Another thing you want to make
a decision around is the
servingFramework.
And I'll get into this in a
sec, but redirect or API.
So what does this actually mean
when we talk about the
servingFramework, right?
And when you create it through
the API, this is something
that you have to set.
By default, it'll be redirect
if you don't set it.
So what does this
actually mean?
Setting the servingFramework to
redirect is basically what
you would get if you created
an experiment
through the web interface.
This is kind of the standard
implementation.
And this is where you have this
JavaScript snippet, and
you place it on your
original page.
And what happens is when the
user visits that page, it
redirects them to the URL that's
been chosen for them,
or the page that's been chosen
for them, the variation.
So when you look at through the
API, when you create an
experiment through the API,
if you look in the list
experiment, you'll see there's
a JS snippet property of that
experiment.
So this is kind of like
a helper property.
It gives you this JavaScript
code that you would want to
use for this particular
servingFramework, and it
provides it, and it fills in the
ID for you automatically.
So if you looked at the response
from the management
API for a servingFramework
that's set to redirect, you
would basically get the
JavaScript code that you would
have seen in the
web interface.
So it's that same JavaScript
snippet.
If you set it to API, the
servingFramework, then you end
up with a JavaScript snippet
that's more intended to use
when you're creating
the experiments
outside of the web interface.
And it provides you with this
helper JavaScript snippet that
you'd want to use as part of
your implementation for the
Content Experiment.
So those are the kind
of two differences.
You could actually set
redirect and use the
JavaScript snippet
from the API one.
It wouldn't make a difference.
It doesn't actually affect
anything else.
It really just changes that
snippet for you to really just
give you-- it's just
a helper for you.
So once you've decided on that,
the next thing you want
to do is you have to actually
choose the variation for the
user when they visit the
experiment page.
So if you're doing redirects,
so the CMS isn't going to
actually just use the
redirect method.
And they would just provide--
so you'd want to just add the
snippet to the page when you
render to the user.
And it would take care of the
client-side redirect for you.
It would basically act the same
way as it would for the
web interface implementation.
If you're doing an API
implementation for Content
Management Systems, so now
you're handling everything
yourself, there's a couple
things you would need to do.
One is you're going to be making
the choice server side.
So that means you need to query
the management API,
understand what variations are
active for this particular
experiment, and then you'd have
to serve that variation
to the user based on the weights
that you have for that
variation and whether they
should be included or not in
that experiment.
And this can be all done through
the Management API.
And then you actually want to
show them the variation that
you chose for them.
And then you need to just store
on the client side.
The way I would do it is you'd
store it on the client side in
a cookie what variation
was shown to the user.
At that time, when you render
the page to them, you would
include the JavaScript snippet
on the page so that you would
set the chosen variation.
And then finally, you want to
send the experiment data.
And again, if you're using the
redirect method, the JS
snippet will take care of
everything for you.
It's the same as the
web interface.
If you're doing the API, then
you want to use that
JavaScript snippet, and you
want to specify the chosen
variation for this particular
user and this particular
experiment.
And the way you do that
is you use the set
chosen variation method.
And this is all documented in
our solution guides and the
actual code that you would
need to do this.
So definitely take
a look at that.
And then finally, we
want to monitor the
experiment as it's running.
So in the CMS, you can imagine
you'd have an admin panel.
The user would visit the
administration panel, look at
experiments that are currently
running for their site, and
see if there's any outcomes.
And when there is an outcome, if
there's a winner, then you
would want to give them the
option at the time to publish
that particular experiment.
And this can all be managed
outside of GA in the CMS
itself as a plug-in, maybe for
Wordpress or things like this
that you can actually create a
plug-in that would handle all
this stuff.
OK, so another thing people
ask me about is the
statistical engine, if they
want to use their own.
So we do touch on this in the
solution guide a little bit,
but I thought it would be good
to cover it again because
there's a few things that maybe
aren't clear in the
solution guides since
they cover a little
bit different scenarios.
So let's talk about this
statistical engine.
So again, if you're doing a
statistical engine on your
own, defining variations
is still the same.
You're going to use--
maybe you're using a third party
optimization platform.
Maybe you're using a CMS system,
or you're doing the
variations yourself.
But ultimately, you create
different variations, and you
want to run an experiment.
So you would configure the
experiment using the
Management API.
And in this case, it's actually
required that you use
the Management API to create
this experiment.
And that's because you need to
set the servingFramework,
which we mentioned earlier,
to external.
And when you set it to external,
it will actually
disable the multi-armed
bandit.
And then you can run your own
experiments, and it won't
actually affect anything in the
reports related to what
multi-armed bandit would
have normally done.
And again, I think you want to
set the editable in GA to
false because I don't think
you want the user to go in
there and change settings, but
again, this is up to you,
depending on your scenario.
Because you're going to be
handling this all yourself
externally, you might want
to disable the GA UI.
So setting it to external, what
actually happens then is
it disables the engine for
multi-armed bandit.
When you look at the experiment
itself, the
variation weights that are
listed as part of the
experiment will still
be there, but
they'll always be zero.
And they won't get updated
because typically what happens
is twice a day, the multi-armed
bandit, that that
engine will update weights for
variations to determine
whether or not they should be
active and also determine what
percentage of visits should
go to those particular
variations.
So that's disabled completely
when you do external.
Also when you create the
experiment, the objective or
goal is not required.
So you can set it to leave it
empty, and it won't complain.
Whereas if you set it
to API redirect, the
servingFramework, and you try
to create without a goal,
it'll give you an error.
And then the snippet, again,
the JavaScript snippet that
changes depending on the
servingFramework, again
provides this helper
script that you can
use if you'd like.
And it just loads this Content
Experiments JavaScript library.
So if you are doing a web
implementation still, you're
going to want to load this
JavaScript to send us the
experiment data.
So again, if you're doing this
then choosing the variation,
you're in charge.
So it's up to you how
you want to do this.
Whether you flip a coin or
whatever, it's up to you.
But now you're managing this
yourself in terms of what
variations should be shown.
But you still need to send
this experiment data.
So we need to know to get the
reports populated properly.
And when you think back to the
platform, we still need to
know what experiment was the
user exposed to and what
variation did you show us.
Now, you might have your own
variation IDs if you're
doing-- so for example, if
you're another third party
optimization platform.
The user might have set up some
variations, and you have
your own IDs.
And then in Google Analytics,
when you create an experiment,
because you want to replicate
it in Google Analytics, each
variation's going to have its
own ID, which is just kind of
a zero index based
array or list.
So typically, zero is the
original, and then you have
one, two, three, going on.
You can think of those as
IDs for the variations.
So when you send us experiment
data to indicate the
experiment and the variation
chosen, you just need to make
sure that the ID that we have
in our system is the correct
one for the variation that
you've shown because you might
have a different ID
in your system.
So as long as those two match
up, you just send us the
variation data by using the set
chosen variation method of
their JavaScript library.
And that'll ensure that all of
our reports get populated with
the experiment data.
And if you're doing non-web,
then you don't need to worry
about the JavaScript snippet.
You can use the measurement
protocol.
And you can send data directly
to us using the HTTP get
request or post, depending on
what you're trying to do.
And then you're going to
conclude the experiment
because you're going to
decide when it ends or
who the winner is.
And once you've done
that, you won't be
sending us data anymore.
And you can actually review the
reports in GA, though, and
you can have all that data in
there and do segmentation with
user interaction data related
to the experiment.
So it works really well for--
so we did integration with
Visual Website Optimizer, and
they're actually using this.
And they're able to replicate
experiments that they're
running in their system in GA.
So you get this nice
integration.
And you get these really great
reports that are specifically
tailored for Google Analytics
users, and it's great.
Finally, we have non-web
environments.
So this is an interesting one.
You can do things, kind of
examples like maybe a kiosk,
which isn't web-based--
it could be web-based, but maybe
some other environment
where you don't have the
traditional kind of web model
that we normally see.
So again, you're still
doing the same thing.
The five steps still apply.
You're defining your
variations.
You might go into custom
development to do that.
But whatever you're doing, make
sure you've implemented
Google Analytics properly.
So if it's non-web, that means
most likely you're going to be
using the measurement protocol
to send hits to GA.
And then also, you still
need to have a goal and
objective set up.
So what are we trying
to improve?
What is the actual goal that
we're trying to either
maximize or minimize?
So that still stays
kind of the same.
So you can use, in this case,
you can use the web or the
Management API to set up your
experiment, whatever is easier
for you, depending on how
you want to set it up.
When you do things like this
where you don't have in the
web interface where you create
variations that don't really
have a URL, you have to
provide one still.
And it's fine.
It won't validate properly, but
it's fine because you're
just basically setting up the
structure of the experiment in
Google Analytics.
And the URLs don't
really matter.
It's fine.
And then you can still choose
now, at this point, whether
you want to use the statistical
engine from GA or not.
So if you don't,
you can set the
servingFramework to external.
So when you look at this, the
non-web is kind of like the--
depending on what you're trying
to do, it gives you all
the different options you can
use and whether you want to
use this engine or not,
whether you're using
JavaScript or measurement
protocol, you have the
flexibility here.
But you kind of have--
web might be easier for
you, Management API
may make more sense.
It depends on your setup.
What's important to really
consider on the non-web
environment is how you're going
to store information
around particular users and what
experiments they've seen.
So when you think about
the client side, a
user visits a website.
Google Analytics has
a client ID.
We know the visitor has been
exposed to an experiment.
We can store that
into a cookie.
So when they come back again, we
know to show them the same
variation that they were
originally exposed to.
In non-web environments,
this might not be easy.
There might not be a way to
store in the client side, so
you might have to manage this
on the server side.
So this is really important for
you to determine early on
so you can set up your
experiment properly.
And then is it even
applicable?
You may have a kiosk, for
example, where the start to
finish is one user, and you
never expect that user to
return to do something.
So the experiment really
just runs in a
single kind of session.
In that case, maybe storage
isn't important for that
particular user.
And then also, if you're doing
this on non-web environment,
you're going to need to make
variation choices on the
server side.
And that means you're going to
be using management API to
query for experiment
information.
And you need to store that
on the server side.
And you probably want to do
that at least twice daily.
The multi-armed bandit, if
you're using the multi-armed
bandit, it updates these
values twice per day.
So you want to make
sure you have the
latest experiment data.
You would store that on your
side, and then based on the
variation weights in which
experiments are active, you
would make the choice
on the server side.
And this is explained in our
developer docs and how to
actually make these choices.
So for non-web environment,
we still need to
send experiment data.
You always have to send
this experiment
data to Google Analytics.
So once you've shown the
variation to the user, then
you would send the data with
the measurement protocol.
So this will get the reports
populated with the proper data
for your non-web environment.
So very similar, all very
similar in terms of what
you're doing.
Just little tweaks here and
there on what action needs to
be done from the implementation
standpoint.
And then again, it's the same.
Once you've got the experiment
running, you want to monitor
the experiment and then
implement the actual winner on
the kiosk or whatever it is from
the non-web environment.
Again, same as the
other examples.
Nothing changes there.
So just a few tips, additional
questions that people ask a
lot around experiments
and search.
So I've had this
come up before.
So the big one thing people
think off the bat is if you're
doing client-side changes, that
this might be negative,
maybe this SEO and something
might actually affect it.
So there's actually a
great post by the
Google Webmaster Central.
They have a nice post
that explains
these different things.
So I'm just basically using
that information.
But there are a couple things.
So cloaking, when you're doing
changes in the client side and
changing the DOM and
manipulating it, this won't be
considered cloaking.
So cloaking is when you're
actually changing content just
because you've seen Googlebot
come by, and you're going to
change the content because you
know it's a search engine
looking at it.
That's cloaking, so you
should never do that.
But when you change the DOM and
manipulate a page on the
fly when a user visits it, it's
not considered cloaking
because it's not targeted
at a search engine.
So this is fine.
You can do this on client-side
implementations.
Also, if you do have multiple
URLs, you probably want to use
the canonical--
you want to make sure you
indicate which one's the
canonical URL.
And this will help for
search and indexing.
And then finally, if you are
doing redirects, make sure
that they're temporary directs
so the search engine knows
that this isn't permanent, and
it will index appropriately.
And then finally, to reiterate
the point of the
servingFramework, just make sure
if you're using external,
and you want to use your own
statistical method, you have
to create the experiment
through the API.
There is no way right now to
set servingFramework to
external and disable multi-armed
bandit if you're
creating it through
the web interface.
So that's key to understand
how to use your own
statistical method.
And then for servingFramework,
if you're using API redirect,
it doesn't actually affect
the experiment at all.
It will just change the
JavaScript snippet that's
provided for you in
the API response.
So whether you use API
redirects, it's up to you.
If you're going to do a full
complete integration, like a
Content Management System
integration, I just recommend,
if you're not doing redirects
and just use [INAUDIBLE]
API, and then you'll
get the correct
JavaScript snippet for you.
So one other note is that the
Universal Analytics and
Experience, so analytics.js and
measurement protocol don't
currently support experiments,
but it's coming very soon.
So a lot of the documentation
will be updated.
And so once you see that
updated, you'll know that it's
available now.
But all the steps and processes
that we just talked
about are applicable to
whichever one you're using.
But just so you guys know.
And then a few resources.
Again, there is the developers'
site for Google Analytics.
We'll provide these links
for you guys.
There's a good experiments
overview.
And I think that's a good
place to start.
It provides all the links that
we have available and all the
documentation we have available
for experiments.
And then this video will
complement the existing
solution guides that we have
for redirects on the client
side, [INAUDIBLE]
client-side redirects, and
also running server-side
experiments.
So this video combined with that
will really provide you
with a good overview of how to
run advanced implementations
for experiments.
And if you're interested more
about the multi-armed bandit,
there's a great article
that's provided.
I would go through the Help
Center, and they really give
you the details of how it works,
why it's better, or why
it's better maybe for certain
situations, and really gives
you some good detail on whether
you might want to use
that or not.
So I think it's a
great resource.
That's all for today.
So I'd like to thank everybody
for joining me.
If you have questions,
feel free to
post them in the moderator.
And I will definitely take
a look and answer those
questions online for you.
So thanks again, and join us for
our next Analytics Live,
which we'll post on
Developers Live.
Thank you very much.
Have a good day.